moi je pense que nous nous hons ce soir
à la chose à laquelle nous nous hons
depuis que nous sommes
rentrer c'est l'impossibilité de
transmettre et de
traduire c'était de mondes absolument
différents ici c'est ici avec un
vocabulaire qui représente des choses
qui représente des sentiments et le camp
pour nous c'était là-bas c'était là-bas
c'est quel chose absolument
d'intraduisible nous nous heurtons nous
avons l'habitude les uns et les autres
de vouloir en parler notamment aux jeune
et bien c'est très difficile et nous
avons l'impression et bien que nous
avons failli à notre devoir quand nous
avons terminé cette causerie parce que
c'est cette vie journalière oui c'est
extraordinaire un mon de cadavre euh des
suppliciers qui sont pendus et bien ça
frappe mais quand on on évoque 6 he
d'appel et bien personne personne ne le
ressent personne ne le ressent quand on
évoque un morceau de pain perdu ou un
morceau de pain volé et cette tentation
euh de prendre un morceau de pain quel
est celui d'entre nous celle d'entre
nous qui l'a pas senti une fois et au
moment au moment de faire cette
solidarité quand on demandz une
cuillerée de souple ou un morceau de
pain et bien il faut situer les choses
dans le contexte où elles étaient on
passe dans les rues maintenant on voit
du pain dans les poubelles mais là nous
avions 100 g de pain c'était une chose
qui était absolument indispensable pour
vivre quelques jours et bien on nous a
demandéit d'en donner 10 g pour
quelqu'un qui était plus atteint que
nous et bien personne d'entre nous l'a
fait spontanément absolument personne
l'a fait spontanément il y a eu cette
réaction d'égoïsme qui qui est quelque
chose d'humain et et la grande la grande
victoire et bien c'est que nous l'avons
fait la grande victoire c'est que que
tous nous l'avons fait et c'est ça c'est
ça justement le but le but des SS et
bien c'était d'avilir d'avilir l'homme
pour le rendre abject vis-à-vis de
lui-même vis-à-vis de ses camarades
déportés pour donner d'autant plus de
force au bourreau on frappe beaucoup
plus facilement quelqu'un qui semble
adjc que quelqu'un qui est digne et je
pense que cette expérience du camp et
bien il y a d'autres choses à en parler
qui sont au-delà des tortures qui sont
au-delà des statistiques de la mortalité
mais qui sont en définitive et bien la
victoire la victoire de l'individu
l'individu qui est pétri de de notions
qui ont été inculpées par la
civilisation et puis en réalité et bien
entre les bourreaux et ceux qu'on
présentent comme des victimes et qui
représentaient l'homme et bien ce sont
les victimes qui ont gagné et nous
sommes ici pour en témoigner parce que
sans ces notions sans ces notions
chèrement acquis chèrement défendu et
bien pas d'entre nous serait rentré et
pas un pourrait n'en parler et peut-être
bien que la chose n'aurait pas existé à
l'heure
[Musique]
actuelle